[Musique]
très chers rennes mais vous êtes folle
lé mot frire un palais ceci est une
monstrueuse extravagance madame noir là
nous sommes en guerre nous avons gagné
elle n'est pas finie nous devons
continuer je finirai la reine est une
personne exceptionnelle
il me fait que c'est tous je le sais je
le cède même sans l'avoir vu et j'ai
entendu le mot grosse grosse haye l'aide
personne à part moi n'oserait est jeune
et dimanche elle a été poursuivie par la
tragédie tout le monde même aux hommes
[Musique]
veuillez excuser mon apparence j'avais
espéré être employé ici par vous comme
il vous plaira comme monstre pour amuser
les enfants par exemple
[Musique]
il est important de se faire de nouveaux
amis n'est-ce pas
vous êtes tellement belle cela suffit
vous vous moquez de moi si j'étais un
homme cheikh salem rillieux vous êtes
devenus proches d'abigail c'est une
vipère vous êtes jalouses
vous devez renvoyer abidal je n'en ai
pas envie elles ont tué quelque chose on
a du mal parfois se souvenir s'il en a
chargé le pistolet ou pas où je dois
prendre ma destinée je suis toujours
dans le même camp une mien mais la
faveur est une brise fort capricieuse on
se retrouve vite à dormir parmi des
[ __ ] scabreuses
il s'avère que je peux être parfaitement
déplaisante
vous avez regardé à témoin comment osez
vous savez
je pouvais rester bras croisés à vous
laisser détruire ça prenait du plaisir à
tous il a avoué le sait parfois amusant
d'être reine
allez vous en bien je vais vous roué de
coups jusqu'à épuisement
ma chère amie quelle joie de vous revoir
après l'enfer je suis sûr que vous y
passerez aussi un jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]